[Music]
it's not surprising so many are so
worried about autism
after all the disorder affects roughly
one out of every 115 kids and it's
prevalence seems to be growing
you know you remove certain medications
off shelves because they're deemed
unsafe why not vaccines celebrity
activists raise questions about whether
autism is somehow caused by vaccines in
countless media stories have covered the
alleged link angry parents take to the
streets and thousands more head to court
to try to prove that some of those cases
are linked to childhood vaccines we know
vaccines can cause autism we don't know
as the body-count attorney Jim moody and
his organization safe minds represent
the deep suspicions many have about the
federal government's vaccine policy
they're asking the public to participate
in a mass population experiment to
prevent an infectious disease but they
are not honest with the public and
telling them we do not know what the
risks of taking these vaccines are what
sparked this enormous controversy a 1998
article published in The Lancet a
prestigious British medical journal the
article speculated about a possible link
between autism and the measles mumps and
rubella or MMR vaccine the article
fueled many concerns is the MMR vaccine
safe what about it's mercury
preservative parents have had to wrangle
with all kinds of questions I'm a parent
I'm not a scientist and so I have a job
to worry about my son on a daily basis
there are varying degrees of autism and
Kelly greens son Wyatt has a fairly
severe form like many autistic kids why
it often fixates on repetitive
activities like playing with this
deflated balloon socializing and
communicating are also special
challenges in fact Wyatt is nonverbal
everywhere we go I see little
questioning eyes looking at us
wondering what's going on with my son so
does green blame vaccines for her son's
autism I can't say that I saw the
vaccines injure my son did it not happen
I don't know it seems like the vaccine
was such a logical thing the timing of
when the symptoms start showing up here
at the Cagle Autism Center at the
University of California Santa Barbara
researchers work to better understand
this mysterious condition I can see why
they thought it was the vaccine dr. Lynn
Kegel notes that kids often get
diagnosed with autism near their first
birthday around the same time they get
the MMR vaccine
he's a ninth grader with autism and we
started him painting when he was a
little guy and this is the party scene
but Cagle says timing shouldn't make
parents worried about vaccines we know
at this point it's not the vaccines that
are causing autism but what about the
mercury preservative the source of so
much controversy well it's been removed
and if those who blame the mercury for
autism were right we'd expect to see
autism rates go down after the mercury
was removed from the vaccines we
expected if that was true that the
incidence would go down but they did not
go down she points to preschoolers or
autism has continued to increase even
though their vaccines were completely
free from the mercury preservative known
as thimerosal
likewise in Sweden and Denmark where
rates continued to climb even after the
preservative was taken out autism alert
so what would it take to quell fears
about vaccines The Lancet is saying
basically oops sorry shouldn't have
published that in February The Lancet
retracted the article that stoked so
much fear about vaccines
and the lead author dr. Andrew Wakefield
was reprimanded by British regulators
for acting unethically while conducting
his research I would only plea with
parents you know to believe the science
inquiry is exonerated vaccines here
that's not at all true
the safety of MMR is still an open
question study after study after study
has come out showing that it's not the
cause of autism the British equivalent
of our Institute of Medicine really
study in 2005 looking at all the MMR
safety studies and basically saying the
safety of MMR has not been demonstrated
the study moody sites is very
comprehensive incorporating the findings
of 31 studies but far from highlighting
dangers it finds no credible evidence
that the vaccine is involved with autism
and it actually supports current
policies of mass immunization evidence
that exonerates vaccines continues to
mount so why does so much fear persist
because the scientific studies to
validate the safety of the vaccine
schedule have never been done but Cagle
says we've spent too much time and
energy investigating vaccines and that's
distracting us from finding out what the
real cause of autism is if we could have
all that time and all that money that
were spent on false claims we'd probably
be a lot further along in the
intervention unfortunately researchers
still don't know much about what causes
autism most of the people that are in
the field believe that there are a lot
of causes of autism and that's why
they're pretty much called the autism
now and what's the best way to treat
autism the most current view of the best
way to treat autism is basically blood
sweat and tears it takes a lot of time
but the behavioral interventions seem to
be the most effective for example if
they aren't using communication just
working on getting them to communicate
that's our plan not in other words
pretty much what kelly green does for
white a pure individual somebody
are the best kids on the planet
[Music]